so you right
me my girl worth riding to is hard to
[Music]
find not if you know where to look I'll
miss you every
second major Egan you were the first
pilot assigned of the 100ths me and buck
clev you are in charge of 35 planes and
350 air
crewmen don't you die on me before I get
over there
something big is brewing the E will be
sending up the largest a alada ever
assembled in the history of mankind
straight into Hitler's
territory an incomplete and total air
superiority that's the
mission might be the last pretty face I
ever
[Music]
seen
what's the
move we lead our poor
Strone all then we
do day in day out does something to a
guy doesn't it we here to fight the
monsters the things these people are
capable of they got it coming trust
me Lord guard and guide The Men Who fly
through the great spaces of the sky are
we tusy men or what sir yes sir be with
them traversing the air in darkening
storms or Sunshine fair I think we may
be done we are going to sit here and
take it we're going to stick with our
mission as long as we can
fly we won't go without a fight
[Music]